back to school is upon us
have those words ever had a sweeter
sound
and with the students returning to the
classroom this fall
it is time for some new clothes and i am
so excited to be working with the
children's place
somewhere i've shopped as a parent since
my kids were born
they are the go-to place for any and all
children's back-to-school wardrobe needs
now
we have some students in our studio
today looking for new outfits and
joining us here to share the latest
back-to-school fashion trends is my
sister in all things beauty and
fashion and a true authority santa
roberts rossie
hello can you believe he's back to
school
back to school ever had the meaning that
it has in the last hundred years
i'm equally excited and terrified at the
same time
you know getting your kids out the door
can be super hairball
and you want to make it as peaceful and
productive as possible even if they
don't have a uniform for school
is to make a uniform up there's some
really easy tips
to help people do this like buy in bulk
buy the same thing three
times so you can just rotate through it
have the style formula so
every day they know what the system is
and also like buy neutral colors then
with pops of personality in it
jackson you're gonna come on out
[Music]
this is something that any parent can
easily adopt
we start with a crisp white sneaker a
classic
and then these little khaki shorts i
love a cardigan
layers are really important right now
you're going through this transitional
season
and this backpack always think about
loads of compartments in backpacks
jackson i'd like to ask you how you feel
in this outfit
it feels comfortable that's
bingo that's what you need the kid to
say well
thank you jackson i think you look
incredibly handsome
thank you thanks jackson
all right how about for girls here we
have nuna
modeling
[Applause]
one of the reasons that i as a parent
have been a big children's play shopper
is because i feel
very comfortable with the price point
this is how real
parents shop this is how real kids live
i love the idea of this kind of like
rough and tumble boots but then with
this cute girly sock which actually nuna
chose the skirt is great
it's trend it's perfect for fall the
t-shirt
hides a multitude of stains and then it
comes to those personality pops right
the sparkle of the headband
the sequin backpack how do you feel in
your clothes
cozy
thank you luna and jackson and zanna
i love the children's place and i thank
them so much
for getting nuna and jackson ready today
but
there's something else i am so excited
to announce that from now until
september 7th
the children's place is helping families
across the country
celebrate kids getting back into the
classroom by giving away
1 000 to 1
000 families across america that is 1
million
wow oh thank you children's place and
you
can enter for a chance to win by going
to a children's place store
downloading their app and signing up for
it so
thank you children's place for
everything that you do
you